All right.
What's up, Dean? Now your name is Dean
Works, huh?
>> What's up?
>> Change your name again.
>> Today I have just two questions.
>> Okay.
>> The first question is the all prophets
in the Old Testament, did anyone knew
about the Trinity or Jesus?
>> Yes.
Who?
>> They all did. David, Abraham, they all
did. I mean, yes.
>> Moses said in Deuteronomy 46, "Here, O
Israel, your Lord, your God is one."
>> What is it?
>> Deuteronomy.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> 464.
I'm confused about that.
>> Yeah,
>> you you are Lord, your God is one.
>> Yeah, the Trinity is not three gods. It
is one God. I don't know what you how
you
>> Holy Spirit, the father, the Jesus,
three. How can be it one God?
>> So wait, hold on. No, let me explain to
you. That could see. So you're saying
you can't be one in one way if you're
more than one in another way. Is that
what you're asking me?
>> Yeah. Like
>> so
>> the old prophets in the Old Testament
all knew about the Trinity.
>> Yes. Yes, I did.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, but you're asking me about the
word one.
>> You think equal one?
>> 1 * 1 * 1 is what?
>> One.
>> 1 / 1 / 1 is what?
>> One to the third power is what?
>> One.
>> Okay. Now you answer the question. So
even mathematically you just refuted
yourself because when you go to a higher
level of math you can have three ones
still equaling one. So if you can do
that with math you're saying God is less
complex than math.
>> Uh no like
>> okay now let me ask you another
question. I'm answering you. Let's stay
on the one part. I'm going to show you.
If you have a cube, one cube, one cube,
how many sides does one cube have?
>> Uh, one cube has four sides.
>> No, no, it has six.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Sorry.
>> How can one cube have six sides? That's
a contradiction, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, it's a contradiction.
No,
>> like it has six sides, but it's a one
cube.
>> No, it can't be. If it's more than one
side, it can't be one cube. That's what
you just told me.
>> Yeah.
>> How can one cube have six sides, man?
That's a contradiction. If it's one,
it's one. Can't be more than one side.
No. No. Okay. Now, triangle.
How many sides does a triangle have?
Uh triangle had three sides.
>> No. If it's a triangle one, it can't
have three sides. See, that's what
you're telling me.
>> Yeah.
>> So, do you believe God has attributes
that are not the same?
>> Oh my god, you are confusing me.
>> No, I'm not, man. Okay. The God you
believe in, Allah, does he have
attributes that are not the same? Does
he have multiplicity of attributes?
>> Yeah.
>> No. If he's one, he can't have more than
one attribute. I'm sorry. Sorry. It
doesn't work.
>> Okay. I have another question. You won
this first one.
>> Go ahead.
>> Another question. When Jesus became
human, he was fully God and fully human.
Of course, he never stopped being God.
>> Then when he prayed to the father, he
prayed to himself.
>> How many times
How many times I'm going to explain to
you the trinity means the father is not
the son. The son is not the spirit. The
spirit is not the father. They're not
the same person. They have the same
nature. So when Jesus prays to the
father, he's not praying to himself
because he's not the father. They're not
the same person. This is why we say
trinity try unity three and one and
three. Why do you always confuse the
trinity?
>> Okay. So
another one my last question. Allah he's
not trinity right?
>> Yeah.
>> Why does he pray to himself?
>> Where he prayed to himself? Let me show
it to you. I'm glad you asked me. I have
a lot of articles on this.
Okay.
All right. Here you go. Let me enlarge
it.
Allah according to the Quran and the
Sunnah, he prays to himself. I have a
lot of articles on this. Let me enlarge
it.
>> Which verse?
>> Oh, well, I'm going to get there. Al
Bakra,
ayah 157. What does the word salawat
mean?
bakr chapter 2 ayia 157 it says
what does the word salawat mean salawat
>> uh I don't know
>> salawat is the plural it means prayers
so it says upon them rest the prayers
and mercy of from their lord your lord
He prays prayers salawat. Who does your
Lord pray to when he prays for
believers?
>> Oh my god.
>> Okay. Well done. I'm going to show you
more. 33:43
a
chapter 33:43.
He it is who prays you
for you and his angels you
okay you're listening
you listening or you busy
>> I'm listening
>> Allah it is who prays for you and his
angels too to bring you forth out of the
darkness into the light for he is
merciful to believers so why is Allah
praying with the angels praying to
himself to bring people into his Like
the word is salah means pray.
Who's he praying?
>> Okay,
I don't have answer to that.
>> How about this one? 3356. Verily God and
his angels pray you salah.
That's the verb salah. Allah and angels
are praying for the prophet. Oh you who
believe pray saloo for him. So Allah
with the angels and believers pray for
Muhammad. Why is he praying for
Muhammad?
>> Uh, I don't know, man.
>> Like I have the third most quick
question.
>> All right. What's the other question
now? So,
>> yeah, this question I'm not trying to
prove Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. I'm just asking you, not
>> what you said slowly. You said,
>> hold on, brother. I want you to hear
what you just said. You saidam, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You know what that means? Sallam.
>> Yeah. What it means?
>> What is salah?
>> I don't know.
>> It means Allah's prayers beyond
Muhammad. You just asked Allah to pray
for Muhammad when you said
that's what means
Allah
Allah's prayers on him was and his
peace. So you just ask Allah to pray for
Muhammad. Why?
>> Okay. So anyways,
>> okay. Go back. My this question is like
if a pro if if a prophet makes a
prophecy
>> and it comes true. I'm not trying to
prove prophet Muhammad.
>> Yeah, but we did that last time.
Deuteronomy 13. I
>> if if makes a prophecy and it comes
true, then he is a true prophet.
>> No, I answered that to you last time you
were here, brother. Didn't I remember
Deuteronomy 13:es 1 to10? I showed you.
God said that there'll be dreamers and
false prophets who make a prophecy that
will come true, but it's not from God.
And the way you're going to know if a
prophet is prophesying from God because
he's going to command you to follow the
true God that was revealed by the
prophets before him. So if a prophet
tells you this is going to happen and it
happens, but he says come follow other
gods, he's a false prophet. I already
address that. And last question.
>> Okay. So, how how can we prove that a
pro some prophet is a true prophet?
>> Because he will not contradict
the revelation
that was already established and
confirmed by the prophets before him.
>> Okay.
>> So, when you are going when you are
going to be live again?
>> Uh, I'll be here for a couple hours.
>> No. Uh, next day.
>> No, no. If you email me, you say, "Hey,
can you go live at this time?" I'll do a
live stream. Will you let me know?
>> Don't tell me. Send me.
>> Say, "Hey, I'm ready at this time."
>> Okay. All right.
>> If you don't see my emails,
>> I do see your email, but I can't respond
because I'm not going live. You say,
"Send me leak."
>> I can't send you link if I'm not live.
>> Okay.
>> So, you tell me, "Hey, I'm free this
time."
>> Two, three days I'll get all information
and then I will go. Refute me. Destroy
me for Allah.
>> I will.
>> Thank you. Appreciate it. Okay, man.
>> Uh, okay.
>> All right, buddy. No question. You okay?
You have more questions?
>> No, I don't have more questions.
>> We'll pray for you, Abdullah. We'll pray
for you. Take it easy.
>> Okay, buddy.
>> Uh, I I have just a question. One more.
>> Okay, go ahead. as you said that the uh
the tablets of Torah in the ark of
covenant are pure truth.
>> Are what?
>> What?
>> Are truth?
>> Okay, that you asked me that same
question last time.
>> Yeah. Uh are uh they are the truth. And
do you know which verses are in the
tablets of Torah?
>> The covenant.
>> The tablets would be what God wrote by
his finger that would include at least
the ten commandments.
>> Yeah. We don't know that uh which uh
those ten commandments are.
>> Yes, we do. It's in Exodus 20,
Deuteronomy 5. They're mentioned.
>> Okay. Okay. That was my question.
>> Oh, you got it, buddy.
>> Okay.
>> Come back and destroy me for all his
messenger. Okay.
>> Okay. Um I'll come back and I'll just
cook you.
>> Be good.
Will you use halal uh seasoning?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, good. Because I need to burn my my
lard. Use my lard. Okay, front.
>> Okay,
>> thank you, buddy.
All right, there you go.
Shishka.
Rumble. Make rumble great again. Little
Caesar. TKD man in the beginning.
I like this kid. Pray for Abdullah. He's
a good kid.